皆さんは
秘密基地好きですか僕が小学校の頃はなんか友達3人組とかで木の上に日々的作ろうと
思って近くに映る木の板とかダンボールとか色々集めてい見て基地を作って上で場合は
行ってたんですよ
3日で壊れましたけど保護さんにも怒られました機密費家のローンはみなさんわかり
ますか
あの親にわざわざれない誰に泳ぎられない決して注意のされない
楽園秘密基地安の感動は今も忘れておりません肇社長ですというわけで僕この家に秘密
基地を作ろうと思ったんですけどももうも泊まった日見てきてみたいなところがあって
むずい僕だの秘密基地のって
礼儀としては誰にも邪魔されない場所であのなぜか外
ちょっと狭目二年これが秘密基地の定義だと思うんですよねこのインナーがパッと探し
てみたんですけどなかなか張飛見せして作り3度しかなかったので今回はこちらを買っ
てみました
秘密基地が打ってマーサー会がちゃんですよ
おやつユアンコクーンってかなぁここに写真が
だと思うんですけれどもこういう感じでですね浮いてるテント
みたいなのも作れるんですよこれも見た瞬間即買いだと思っちゃいましたもうちょっと
上げてみましょう
あれ効果待てが頭が次
言われてるの方がかなり入ってますで難しそう
待ってまず本格的だな内容量から見てかなり
月7日レアアースゲイナーなるほど値段どんぐらいだけどしか4万円とかだった聞き
ますないんだっ今値段調べたんですけど73090えんでしたやっぱり
秘密基地ってそう安くないんですよ架空んってども安いですね作り方はもう書いちゃっ
てまぁテント作るね
なんかして何かするんですけどこの折り方じゃないってことはどうやって下りるまあ
それとこれ何が大事かと言いますと方面ちゃんと吊下げなきゃダメなんですよこれ
ずっとやろうと思ってるんですけどもつい下げる場所がなかなか無くて困ってるところ
に僕が発見してしまいました
ありゃあかんおっぱいってくれ日水土を作るこそ行きましたこちらベランダでござい
ますなかなかで上に引っ掛ける場所がなくてどこにしようかと思ったんですけども
桂橋ご飯絞って強いのしてますか人が登っても大丈夫ということは人がブラウザと多分
大丈夫なんですよ重さ的にはてこと足号こうだかうまいこと心にビャーッ手をかけて
チョコに来て吊るしたら市御津必要作れるのかと思いまして
まずはちょっと組み立ててみましょうよねー
冷静さとはすげーな本格的こういう感じねぇ
それは苅田港なるでもらって a
3件なんか弦すべき場所見えましたちょっと
江一派に気がすんだよなこうやってたらここへ引っ張るんだよ
いや絶対コレだぜってーこれいっぱるるはいちょっと今触ってみた感じ多分もう潰した
方がいい気がするんではしご先にこの像空にかけちゃいます毛糸をかける場所をつくっ
てからちょっと作業に入ろうと思いますが
びっくりすモーターいますよって
ブーブー言いませんよっちょれ殺さてけどまず by あきますっ
ban
uh
かけるぞねー
島根よねこれぞ頑張りますの
ウォーズ今きますね一生 pos bendel ran ウェイ
ぐらい上の人なぜこれらゲストここれで大久保さんバランスとれました時でまず人が
キャッツにぶら下げるかどうかのチェックをしますテントぶら下げるようのバイヤーが
ここにいるんですけどもこれがその人の重さに耐えられるかどうか僕がぶら下がって
落ち着いたらまず無理ですからそれの確認だけ下げにしてしまいます安全第一のため
ヘルメットを着用しますもっと過ぎたら知りますからね
みんな編ベスト一戦92倍を探し回っていきますねないん
持った
あ大丈夫かなん
あっ張り切るベルギーでぺぽよ客っぽいです
ok 入ってるけどまぁお寿司て早速作っていきましょうまずにテントを持っている
からされてみようか
これもとかじゃないこれはいはいそうです山いい感じに浮いてますね
おっ今日極刑多分できないという感じ
こんな感じでしたからまだよくわかんないと思うんですねをつくっていきましょう
ん
[音楽]
うぇい
幅でめっちゃでかいぞこれ多分
まだまだ買えるよ
腰がそう1個ですいやもうこれでお腹いっぱい見たと彼ならないなぁ
ここですがここはこれやっほぉ
ってどうせて俺の空に下がったじゃなくてこれ可能な
ねこれ怖いよもうこれでいいわけないよねー
ねっまって本当でおふざけでこれ
10型
[音楽]
me
ok さにおっおおっ
えーすごいずれやばいよねー
ちょっとあとなんか縛ります
完成しましたこれがあなたは私のた公家がこれがちょっと不安なんですけど新しい部屋
です
やはり響いてきたんでも外にないとダメだねぇこういう感じですね措置を回転するもう
これ取り上げて完成しました
ちょっと袋の難しかったんですけどもうその分多分安定感がすごいしっかりした方なん
だと思います
また天井との兼ね合いですねかーっ
ととりあえず乗るしかないよね乗ってみます
またまた今までお大丈夫じゃあさっそく乗ってみます上から落ちてくるんだけど本当に
危ないですからね
マウスでこうよ by ぴょんぴょんっ
画質じゃあ汗話します
不安
[音楽]
あっ
それじゃ乗れてるなら包まれてる撮れてるううううう
すごいすごいなんっ
[音楽]
ブーブー
4強がっヤバイっっ
だねばいばい
お美味しい
うん俺
ni
やっほー2
[音楽]
me
dea
ana あっ